there's been a new ipad and a
transformer prime in this house for the
past week and a half or so and i still
haven't been able to decide which one
makes a better pair with my samsung
galaxy nexus so
this video is your opportunity to
convince me one way or the other which
would make a better choice they're
basically the same hardware at this
point from the back casing to the
cameras to the buttons so it comes down
to what you use the tablet for so let's
take a look at my tablet setup shall we
and leave a thumbs up on this video it
really helps out let's go
so we'll begin with my ipad setup and
this is only because i'm a bit of a noob
of with ios and it you know it doesn't
take a lot to figure out but this is my
wallpaper and i'll have of course the
link to this in the description
basically it's a grid of icons i don't
have to explain that you guys already
know how ios works and i'm a really
really heavy google apps user so i have
a lot of third-party stuff that'll help
me make up for the fact that i'm on an
ipad here but most of the time i'm not
using anything from apple so all the
apple stuff is in this folder here and i
wish i could get it off the home screen
somehow or just remove these icons or
something but that's the way ios works i
can't get rid of them
either way i have some of the google
services like google maps i also have
google tasks in here and i have google
reader in the form of an app called
r-e-e-d-e-r pretty good app for reading
google stuff i also have google calendar
on here so i am making the use of the
most of the google stuff that i possibly
can but the most important app here is
the google search app and this was
recently updated for the retina display
and it allows me to use a whole bunch of
google applications and web services
without having them like i'm not on
android so basically let's see google
photos this will be the stuff that i've
uploaded via google plus on my profile
which is in the description uh google
calendar of course which is probably one
of my most heavily used google apps you
can see that works very nicely here and
check out google plus there's no real
good google plus app for the ipad so i
mostly stick to it on the web
so there it is i am using a lot of this
particular application
on the ipad just because it is that good
and it's kind of freaking out over here
but yeah i really do like this updated
for the retina display brand new and
free so other than that my ipad setup is
pretty chill i have uh these apps in the
dock here they have gmail wolframalpha
is a boss love that app go over here to
the side these are kind of the third
party things so
a game i just downloaded called
metalstorm it was free you know
masters 2012 a golf tournament coming up
that i'm really excited for
flipboard because you guys all told me
to get flipboards so i've got flipboard
it's not that
great
don't hurt me for saying that flickr
plus i'll just open up because
this is a great application for just
flying through pictures uh okay and this
is uh i happen to search ferrari and i
got some pretty sick pictures here so
yeah my ipad is pretty much uh noob
status right now if you guys have any
suggestions for applications that'll
spice it up they are definitely
appreciated for a google user anyway
my transformer prime is also looking
very simple but that's because i've made
it the way i've wanted to make it so
here is my home screen set up with the
transformer prime got a widget here to
turn rotation on and off and brightness
i also got a shortcut to the calendar
here in the form of a widget with the
time on it and they got my most used
applications down here at the bottom
google plus google reader google's
youtube
the twitter app is called twica browser
google chrome google calendar over here
to the right we have more settings and
stuff that i more accurately
actively use over here on the left is
our beautiful weather widget oh it's so
pretty um that always gives us the
temperature it's going to suck tomorrow
i'll be very cold and i have spotify
google music and our google gallery and
a bunch of games and my google mail
widget so as you can see a very very
heavy user of google services and that's
why they are all loaded up on here and i
have a lot of games i have asphalt and i
have google earth is pretty nice but
i've said the word google about 75 times
in this video if you guys haven't
already understood yeah if you have any
suggestions to to help me sway my
decision or if i should get the ipad or
the transformer prime you should
probably leave them in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video give it a thumbs up as that really
does help me out a lot uh the ratings
are appreciated either way i'll talk to
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching
peace
[Music]
you